we talking about direct some problem in
the streaming model and this is joint
work with a new bra let me just start
you by reminding you about the direction
problem so the direction problem is just
ask whether if you perform k
computations kay independent
computations in parallel whether they
require k times more resources or is
there a clever way to somehow combine
the computations so that you can save on
the resources we want to study this
problem in the streaming setting and so
for that let me remind you about the
model so a streaming algorithm doesn't
see its whole input advanced the inputs
arrive in an online fashion for some
part of the input arrives x1 that
streaming algorithm computes something
and stores it it memory and the next
part arrives the stream algorithm
computes something else based on its
previous memory state and this input and
this process goes on until it sees the
whole input and computes of function so
throughout this talk I'm going to assume
that the inputs come from some
distribution so there is some joint
distribution on x1 to xn from which the
inputs are sampled and the algorithms
might be randomized so they might toss
independent random points at each step
to compute the answer so the standard
measure of complexity of a streaming
algorithm is the maximum memory used by
the algorithm at any time step so you
measure what is the maximum size of each
of these memory states that you need to
store so here is a simple example of a
function being computing the streaming
model so consider this function the LX
frequency moment function which has been
considered a lot in the streaming
literature so the input stream is just
numbers from 1 to N and a frequency of
an of a number a in the stream is just
how many times it appears and you want
to take it to the LS power and compute
the sum so you can so so here I'm going
to just do it in the trivial way so you
just store a big table of how many times
you have seen
each and each element in the stream and
at the end you have a count of all the
elements and you just compute this
function and this trivial algorithm it
can it requires memory and login at
every time step just to store this label
and from a big line of research in the
streaming literature this bound is
almost tight even for approximating this
function so i hope the model is clear
enough even for people who are not
familiar with it and okay and if you
have any questions please ask so now we
want to study the direction problem in
this model so now the streams they come
in parallels to their k streams and they
come in parallel so at the first time
step you see the first element of each
of the streams and you compute something
the next time step you see the second
element and this goes on until you
compute the function on all the streams
and the question we want to ask if is
that if these k streams they are sampled
independently and identically from some
distribution whether computing this one
to the K copies of the function it
requires k times more memory
so it turns out that it's a little bit
subtle to define to formalize this
question in this model so here is an
example which is very illustrative in
this respect so consider the following
distribution on the inputs so you you
have a stream of length n you randomly
choose a block of n over K cubed input
where there is actual data otherwise the
stream is all zeros so if you sample k
streams from this distribution
independently independently then with
high probability they are going to look
like this so with high probability when
there is data in one stream there will
be no data in any other stream and and
so now you can run your algorithm that
computes the function on a single stream
independently on each of the streams and
when you're processing one stream then
no I mean no other stream requires any
processing so the maximum memory used by
this is this straightforward way of
computing each computing f1e stream
individually will not increase at all
I think as opposed to these you say
computer all the ps3 the original
problem didn't care about distributions
either it just like it's a stream in
this computer yeah but then the
algorithms are randomized right so here
we are considering like I mean point you
to the hardness of proving your bones
for this a suppose I necessary you
saying this entropy defining the
distribution well I mean also this is
what we get proof showing what
proportion okay why this was too much
okay no way you're done dealing with
stream 1 hmm so you just compute the
answer and answer requires very little
memory so that's like it's not that it
the end you are to provide your meals at
the end you have to compete on Lancers
oh so that's it for me very little
memories so he can just store the
answers and carried through so i hope
think so too you know so but something
else is going on in this example if you
look more closely you see that I mean
you're still processing k streams so
like the average memory per time step
required to compute this function is
still increase by a factor of K because
you still you are doing like k times
more processing so essentially this is
the question we want to study whether
with this complexity measure the direct
sum a problem holes
so let me define it more formally so the
average memory used it's just a so you
take the expectation over the inputs and
the randomness used by the algorithm and
this is just the total memory for every
time step and then you just scale it by
the number of time steps so this is the
formal definition example these are all
zeros right so you don't you have very
little memory that you want to when you
see only blocks of zeros you don't use
any memory at all for those things but
in this case is it true that it
increases by K it doesn't for this
example right it increases by K because
I mean this is just the total memory
used by the algorithm so here you are
using the memory for just one stream
here using I mean here using the same
amount of memory for the same stream so
in the end I mean the total memory it
decreases by a factor of K
so another I mean so this is a
particularly natural complexity measure
to consider in it by itself and in fact
some non streaming you're bound already
give you lower bounds for average memory
so so we want to study whether if you
want to compute function on K streams in
peril whether the average memory
increases by K so let me now come to the
main theorem that we proved just
following if your input stream x1 to xn
is independent and you require memory em
to compute the function on single stream
then 4k streams the memory required is
this quantity might be even feared so
let me explain it so when the number of
streams is really large K is really
large then and the memory required to
compute the function on a single stream
is at least an then you get something
non-trivial here
i will discuss at the end about like
possibly improving the parameters and
open questions related to that at the
end so this is what we prove and and the
rest of this talk I'm going to give you
a proof of this theorem and for that I
need one basic fact from information
theory k need to be bigger than aim yeah
yeah so so it could be I mean it could
be realized it would be n cubed or
things like that so no so we're
measuring the average memory so you see
the average memory can be a number
that's smaller than one and it's still
not revealed you know if your algorithm
uses one you know ten bits of memory in
some place and you're saying if there
was a single stream and the to answer is
M over N naught M right the average
memory when you say it that's not the
Avenue none on is the average not
establish memory so sorry sorry for the
rest of this talk whenever I say a
memory I will mean average memory now so
this is yeah okay so that Candice I need
to be bigger a nice to bigger than
okay so the basic fact from information
theory that I need is just super
activity of which your information just
that if you have n random variables
which are independent condition on Z
then the which information between all
of them and why connection on Z is at
least the mutual information between it
each of them and why condition on C so
let me start with the proof so the high
level outline is this that is going to
argue by contradiction so suppose we
have like this magical algorithm for K
streams that uses very small memory and
then we are going to use this algorithm
to design an algorithm that computes f
on a single stream with small memory and
I mean this is a contradiction because m
is the minimum amount of memory required
to compute the function on a single
stream there are several steps in the
planar proof so first we are going to
argue that if your algorithm uses very
little memory and computes answer on all
k streams there is some stream about
which it cannot remember watch
information so for this you need to
define a measure of complexity for an
information measure for streaming
algorithms and here is one very natural
measure that we define and use this we
call it the translational information
content so essentially you take the
mutual information between the memory at
time T and the input at time T
conditioned on the previous memory state
and then you take the average over all
the time steps so inverse this is
essentially the average amount of
information the algorithm learns about
the next input based on what it already
knows one easy to see fact is that this
is bounded by the average memory
so let me come to the step one of the
proof now so just by a super additivity
the mutual information between the
memory at time T and the th element of
all the key streams these represent I
mean the superscript represent the
streams is at least the mutual
information between the memory at time T
and the th element of each stream so now
just by averaging you get that there's
some stream for which the algorithm
remembers learns very little information
conditioned on what it already knows and
this is bounded by the information
content / k which is that most of memory
/ k
so this so you coming back to our plan
now we know this fact that there is some
stream about witched algorithm remembers
really information and we are going to
use this fact to design and randomized
algorithm that computes the function on
a single stream and it might still use
very large memory so it won't give us a
contradiction but it will have small
information content and I mean to do
this there is also very natural way so
you want the basic ideas you want to you
have this magical parallel algorithm
that uses very little memory and you
want to somehow run it with a single
stream so you do the natural thing you
take your input stream you embed it at
this location about which the algorithm
stores very little information so you
would say a question and you generate
other strength randomly and so all the
stick I mean everything is independent
here so you can do this in fact and then
you just run the algorithm for K streams
and it outputs dancer on all the streams
and then you just output the Jays answer
and from what we saw before the
information content of this algorithm is
bounded by this number is small
going back to your plan now we have a
randomized algorithm that computes the
function on a single stream with small
information and the last step is to
compress this algorithm which I mean
that to show that if you if you have an
ax streaming algorithm it's a small
information content then you can somehow
simulate it with small memory
I should know it's there no question so
what we want to do here is that here we
have our original algorithm which get
some input store something in memory and
what we want to do is that we want to
store something that breaks the
dependency between x1 and m1 which we
could store so somehow this w one that
we want to store it breaks the
dependency and it exactly extracts the
information about x1 that we need to
carry on rest of the simulation and I
mean if you have this we can just repeat
this for rest of the steps and we'll
have a error-free simulation so we just
like repeat this fact so what we want is
that our inputs are coming from some
distribution x1 so there's x1 be the
random variable for that and m1 is the
random variable denoting the memory and
we want a random variable W one that
kind of makes them independent and once
you have that you can just store that
and you can forget about x1 because you
have all the information that you need
essentially in WR should be sure yeah
and and it it would have a problem one
is short that's what we actually require
so here is a very natural attempt on to
you see that you want this so you can
ask this question that given any random
variables x NM is there another random
variable W such that the blue makes xn
and independent and the entropy of W is
small so the blue requires about the
mutual information between X and M it's
to store as you might guess from the
title of the slide that this is true so
this this question was studied by Viner
long back under the guise of common
information and I mean there are many
known examples where the mutual
information between random variables is
one bit but the entropy of wnew which
makes them independent can be
arbitrarily large okay all is not lost
because something very close is actually
true so it's possible to do this with
some additional randomness and this was
done in a beautiful paper by harsha john
mcallister and rather creation from 2010
and another alternate sampling procedure
was given by brave 1 million guard a
couple of years ago so what they proved
is the following
so for any random variables X and M
there exists two random variables c and
s so that s is independent of X so you
can think of s as some kind of
randomness which is independent of X so
you can sample it ahead of time and use
it and cns they together break the
dependency between X and I'm and in fact
something stronger is true in this case
in this proves at cns they actually
determine the value of m and lastly I
mean the entropy of C condition on the
randomness is small so C requires small
number of bits to store once you have
the randomizer CSU just the yeah it's
just a concatenation of them
so this is very close to what we wanted
so let's go back to our proof sorry s is
randomness source is like you can sample
it and this size does not really matter
I mean and it's going to be infinite in
this case it has infinite suppose so so
let's plug this back in in what we want
so the first step we're just going to
use this random variable C one that is
given by either construction and this
requires some randomness which can which
you can sample the head time and
together these the c1 and the randomness
they determine the value of M one that
you want so the next step you just
sample condition on the value of this m1
and we can just repeat this until you
reach them and this is the error free
simulation of the algorithm on top but
there is something that you have to be
careful about here is that at any time T
you need to remember the entire history
of what you have had sample before so
you need to remember all the c12 CD that
is because at any time stuff CRT your
sampling condition on the previous
memory state which is only determined
once you know the previous CD and this
kind of Cascades and you need to
remember the entire thing so essentially
in this case you need to remember the
entire history of what you're sampling
in order to be able to do the simulation
so also as given by the lemma fire at
all and Raven Annenberg entropy of this
each of these n coatings what you're
storing is about the mutual information
between XD empty and condition of the
previous memory state and once you have
this we can see that at any time T
storing all of c 1 to c 3 CD requires
this many bits and just by plugging in
the expressions we have we get the
following compression lemma that if you
have a streaming algorithm with
information content I then you can
simulate it with memory and times I
essentially so now you might think that
there could be some hope of saving up
this blow-up of n here but it turns out
that this compression lamb is tied for
this information measure so here is a
very simple example so your inputs x1 to
xn they're random bits and your
algorithm just stores them and outputs
them at the end so it's just doing
something they're stupid well so this
algorithm it remembers it learns one bit
of information about the next input at
every time step which we said the
average information learned is also one
bit at every time step but you cannot
hope to have output x1 to xn without
remember without using Omega and average
memory
so the compression the dilemma that we
had was almost died and so but we now we
can go back to our proof of the wrexham
and we can plug the same so we had a
randomized algorithm that computed F why
did you swallow information and using
this compression you get algorithm that
computes F on a single stream and use
this memory less than M I mean the
parameters here are chosen like
carefully to cancel everything so this
concludes the proof and this is the
theorem restated
so now you can ask that better how can
you go about improving the parameters in
this serum and for that you I mean if
you want to use the same approach you
might think of using like a different
information measure which allows you to
do better compressions so another
measure of information that he that is
very natural to define and is we call
the cube lative information content is
essentially you look at the mutual
information between the memory at any
time and all the inputs it has seen so
far and you take the average so in other
words this is essentially the average
amount of information the algorithm
retains about all the input suit it has
seen so far and we show that if the
direct some argument goes through for
even for this information measure so if
you can compress you will get optimal
direct some theorems in this setting so
essentially if you have algorithm which
has cumulative information content I and
it can be simulated with order I memory
then memory required for K streams will
be K times more even when the memory is
constant memory for single stream is
constant
and essentially that brings me to the
end and only there is a natural open
problem related to this question which
is compression to cumulative information
content so we have a algorithm that we
believe Good would actually compress the
kimberley information content possibly
but we are not able to analyze it so
it's there in the paper if you want to
take a look and another natural question
is I mean whether direct some question
to improve the parameters for direction
question for independent distributions
and then to somehow prove direct some
theorems for arbitrary distributions
although this looks pretty hard because
it's not clear how to carry the dread
some arguments and the streams are
correlated and i'm going to give you
another open problem which is just a
purely information through a question
it's related to analyzing the candidate
algorithm that we have and i'm not going
to give you any details on how how it's
related but i'm just like you i'm just
going to let you stare at this so we had
these oviedo already this that for any
random variables X and M there exist
random variable C s such that s is
randomness independent of X they break
the dependency and the entropy of C is
small so now we want to ask whether this
additional condition is true if you have
another random variable which is
independent of X once you know em then
this I mean this construction of cns
they do not give you more information
than what you should in this case which
is the mutual information between xn and
if you want to map it back to the
streaming amazon setting then it's
essentially m is the current memory step
and n is going to be the next memory
step so you want to somehow take that
into account
I think that's all I have to say so
thank you all very much for listening
and